when we started our next speaker is
going to be Georgina Ford from Princeton
telling us about hey everyone so thanks
very much for coming to my talking thank
you for the invitation so today I'm
gonna be talking about non-negative
polynomials and the applications to
learning so this is joint work with my
adviser who gave a talk here a few days
ago and one of our senior thesis
students mihaela so we start with the
basics even though I'm aware that most
of you know and is it this thing so what
is a non-negative polynomial so a
multivariate polynomial P and n
variables x1 4 xn is non-negative if P
of X is greater equal to 0 for any X in
RN so here I've drawn a univariate
polynomial
it's obviously not negative but what if
we're interested in showing that this
kind of polynomial is non-negative it's
a much more complicated polynomial and
it's harder so in fact I'm interested in
something even more than just checking
non negativity of a given polynomial
what I'm actually interested in problems
of the following types so it's what I
call optimizing over non negative
polynomials so it's problems of the
following form so I have a polynomial
here and the decision variables are the
coefficients of my polynomial I have an
objective which is linear and in the
coefficients of my polynomial and
constraints that are fine in the
coefficients of my polynomial and then I
have this extra condition here which is
a non negativity condition and so you
may wonder at this point for age what is
the the point of these kind of problems
why would I be interested in problems of
this type so the most common application
of problems of this type is preneur my
optimization but today I'm going to be
telling you about two different problems
in machine learning that can be cast as
problems of this type so I'm going to
revisit them this is just a brief
introduction to each of them so the
first one is shape constrained
regression so the problem I'm interested
in here is I've got a bunch of data
points and I want to fit a polynomial
regressor for these data points and so
that I minimize for example least
squares but you're on top of usual
regression which I wish to do is have
some kind of shape constraint on this
point no more regressive so this for
example can be monotonous 'ti in the
features or convexity or concavity so
this makes sense in terms of
applications so the typical applications
we have in mind our pricing applications
so for example trying to determine the
of a car so you can imagine if you have
two cars where everything is fixed
except for one feature right which is
age an older car should be less
expensive than a newer car right so we
would have monotonicity in that feature
so we have other applications for
example interest rates for student loans
so this is where this would come into
play in in applications and so how does
this connect back to optimizing of a non
negative polynomials well here we want
to fit a polynomial regressor to our
data and so the derivatives of this
product of this polynomial are going to
be polynomials again and imposing one
ethnicity of a polynomial regressive
arranged as the same as imposing non
negativity of its partial derivatives
which are polynomials over that range
and similarly rate if you have if you
want your polynomial regressor to be
convex right imposing convexity is the
same thing as imposing that the Hessian
of your polynomial are X be positive
semi-definite and if you this is
equivalent to asking that Y transpose
the Hessian of x times y is non negative
any x + y here the hessian is a matrix
with polynomials and trees right and
when I multiply by Y on either side I'm
gonna get a polynomial in x and y and
I'm asking for this polynomial to be
non-negative right so this is how it can
expect optimizing over non negative
polynomials and the second application I
have in mind is difference of convex
programs so for those of you who aren't
familiar with these type of problems so
it's optimization problems with the
following form so you're minimizing some
F 0 of X such that f of X is less than
or equal to 0 but hey you have the extra
constraint that these F 0 F i's are
written as the difference of two convex
functions ok so they can be written as
GI of X minus H I of X and G nhi are
convex here so they appear a lot of
machine learning these these kind of
problems and a main problem that's been
raised in the literature over the past
years has been well if we're given
polynomials of this format right if we
can if we know that these polynomials
can be written as the difference of two
convex polynomials then we're all set
but what happens if we don't have a
structure of this type how can I obtain
a set the structure of this type so
these are the two applications I'm going
to be revisiting throughout my talk I
just want to give you a brief overview
so this one how does this one connect
back to optimizing of a non negative
polynomials again it's the convexity
rate imposing that G and H IB convex is
the same as imposing that Y transpose
the Hessian times Y is non-negative okay
so the outline of the rest of the talk
so I'm going to give a very very brief
introduction to some squares just one
slide to get everybody on the same page
then I'm going to revisit these two
different applications so just I'm sure
all of you know this but what is some
squares polynomial so testing where the
polynomial is non-negative is a hard
thing to do when the degree the
polynomial is greater or equal to four
so a popular surrogate that's used for
non-negative polynomials is sum of
squares polynomials and it's a
sufficient condition for non negativity
and what we like about sum of squares
polynomials is they're essentially it's
a tractable condition to test so testing
optimizing over the set of some squares
polynomials is a semi definite program
okay so back to make sure applications
here so I'm gonna start with monotron
regression so the setting is the
following okay so we have n data points
X I which is a feature vector and Y I
which is our response and I'm going to
assume that we have an underlying
function f here that generates these
points Y I so why I the noisy
measurement of f at X I so I add some
noise here epsilon I I'm further going
to assume that my feature vectors X I
belong to a box B that's included in RN
and on top of all of this I'm going to
assume that I have what we call a
monotonous city profile for a function f
so what does this mean this means that I
know how my function f depends on my
features so this is a vector right an N
by 1 vector and each entry gives you how
this function f depends on the current
feature so if I look at entry J right of
this feature vector if it's equal to 1
it's because I know that my my function
f is when an or something uniquely
increasing with respect to XJ if it's
minus 1 I know it's decreasing with
respect to that variable and if it's
zero it means that I don't there's no
more not Audacity requirements with that
particular feature and so the goal of
this part of the talk is to fit
essentially a polynomial to the data
that has the same monotonous ax T
profile row over my box B okay and so
the two questions I have is can this be
done computationally and how good is
this aprox
Meishan there's a setup clear yeah so
the first result we have is a negative
result in the sense that if I give you a
cubic polynomial P a box B and I'm a not
Elissa two profile row and it's actually
hard to test whether this polynomial has
that monotonous itty profile over the
box but we have an SOS relaxation of
this problem so say we want to impose
write that our polynomial is increasing
with respect to variable J so what does
that mean it means that I want my
polynomial to be non-negative the
derivatives derivative of that
polynomial with respect to that variable
to be non-negative over the box and so I
just relax it so if P has odd degree I'm
going to relax it in this way so I'm
going to require that my derivative of
my polynomial with respect to XJ be
equal to sum of squares polynomial plus
some sum squares polynomial time this
quadratic polynomial here so notice
right that obviously when my ex I
belongs to my box this quadratic is
going to be non-negative I'm multiplying
by a sum of squares which is
non-negative and adding another sum
squares which is non-negative again so
this gives me that when I put onto the
box essentially this polynomial this
derivative of this polynomial is going
to be non-negative so this is indeed a
relaxation of this okay and so now I'm
going to go on to approximation so how
good is our potential approximation so
we have the following result that tells
us that if you give me a new precision
epsilon greater than zero and any C one
function f that generates my my points
so this F has a monotonous duty profile
row then I can find for you a polynomial
P that has a same profile as F such that
F and P don't defer too much over this
box and such that the monotonous 2d
profile of my polynomial can be
satisfied using sum of squares and so
the proof of this theorem I'm not going
to go into it but it uses results from
approximation theory and then putting as
positive silence s
yeah that's a good question so
essentially it's similar to all these
these these theorems that we have so the
degree we're not we don't have it well
we have an expression depending on for
example the minimum of P over the box
which we don't know so the bounds we
can't we can't compute them okay so how
does this perform in experiments so here
this is so we have so this is just a
projection onto one particular feature
so this is actually a multivariate
polynomial that we that we obtained with
our regression and we're projecting onto
one particular feature and with this
feature we know that the function here
is monotonous with respect to this
feature so this is a blue line here this
is the original function that we have so
that we're considering two different
environments the low noise environments
and the high noise environment and what
we're doing is we're doing an
unconstrained regression in pale orange
here and here and a constrained
regression not an equally constrained
regression in dark orange here and as
you can see right in the case of
unconstrained regression especially in
the high noise environment you can see
that we have a lot of overfitting going
on right so this this polynomial here
they're unconstrained regression over
fits considerably whereas our polynomial
because we're integrating this this
notion of you know monotonous itty it's
more robust and it follows more closely
the original function and so we
generalize these results on this
particular figure here so in this figure
what we're doing is we're testing so a
training model over some some date and
then we're testing it so this is again a
low noise environment and this is a high
noise environment and you can see so the
training set so it's in yellow and in
purple the training when we when we do
this regression over the training sets
so obviously right the unconstrained
version does better on training because
it has this capacity to overfit but our
model does better when it comes to the
testing right because we have this
additional information that we're taking
into consideration okay so this is the
testing this is the testing and in reg
this is the testing here
okay so now I'm gonna move on to
difference of collects programming any
questions I'm gonna show in regression
what was D oh yeah so dere's actually
what's written so it's the horizontal
axis number features OD is the degree of
the polynomial yes yes that's really the
number features here's like seven I
think
okay so now we're gonna I'm gonna
revisit the difference of convex
programming example so just to remind
you what the problem was so I'm
interested in problems of the following
form right I'm interested in minimizing
F 0 of X such that f of X is less than
or equal to 0 where fi is this
difference of two convex functions and
I'm going to restrict myself to the
particular case where my functions are
polynomials and the question I'm
interested in is if I'm not given a
decomposition of this type right how
would I obtain a decomposition of this
type so this boils down to the following
crest question right if I give you a
polynomial f can you give me back to
convex polynomials G and H such that F
is equal to G minus H and at this point
you might have a lot of questions like
you know does such a decomposition
always exist can it be efficiently
computed is it unique so I'm going to
answer these questions in the second
part of this talk so the first question
is about existence and to understand
existence well how I showed that such a
decomposition does always exist you need
to understand just briefly what being
SOS convex is so as I mentioned before
write a polynomial F is convex is
equivalent asking that Y transpose it's
Hessian at x times y be non-negative for
any X and wine RN
ok so this is we're asking that a
polynomial in x and y be non-negative so
I can replace the non negativity
condition by a sum of squares condition
and so this is what we call so f is a so
as convex if this is satisfied right
it's a sufficient condition for
convexity and what is nice about it is
that it's checkable via semi definite
programming and so the theorem we
actually have is the following so if I
give you any polynomial you can give me
back to SOS convex polynomials such that
you know F is equal to G minus H and
then as a corollary as any SOS convex
polynomial is a convex polynomial this
means that any polynomial can be written
as the difference of two convex
polynomials ok and so the proof of this
theorem is actually more general very
easy to show so the theorem the general
theorem is the following so if you have
a full dimensional cone over vector
space then any element of your vector
space can be written as the difference
of two elements in the cone so that's
the more general theorem and it's easy
to show so let's take a look at the
proof so I have in my vector space
here I have my cone okay all right it's
four-dimensional and I have an element V
that I want to decompose as the
difference of two elements in the cone
so I have one element here which I take
to be in the interior of ki no such a
thing exists right because my cone is
four dimensional which I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna draw a line between V and K
and on this line I know there's a point
that's still in the cone because the
Crone's four dimensional that is neither
K nor V and this is simply what I write
here in this equality and then I just
rearranged this equality and I obtained
that my point V can be written as a non
negative scalar times an element in the
cone - a non-negative scalar times an
element in the cone so essentially it
can be written as the difference of two
elements in the cone okay and how is
this applied to a particular setup for
an R such a very interested in showing
that any polynomial can be written as a
difference of two SOS convex polynomials
so here I'm going to take my vector
space to be the set of polynomials of
degree to D and in n variables and I'm
going to take my comb to be the set of
SOS convex polynomials of degree 2 D and
in n variables and I'm going to get the
result that I wanted I just need to show
that micronus 4-dimensional and this I
can do by showing that some of X I
squared to the D is in the interior of
the comb so this actually answers two
questions right so it answers the
existence question we know that such a
decomposition exists and it also answers
that efficient how can we compute this
question we just need to solve a problem
of this type so we're going to solve the
following problem we're going to look
for the coefficients of G and H such
that F is equal to G minus H and G n H
RSOs convex and this is going to be a
semi definite program and we guarantee
that such a problem is always going to
be feasible right because we show that
such a decomposition always exists and
in fact in the paper we showed that we
can do this using linear programming or
second-order common programming but I'm
not going to discuss this yeah okay so
at this point while we aren't so just as
a reminder right we were interested in
this question if I give you a polynomial
f can you find convex polynomials G and
H such that F is equal to G minus H does
such a decomposition always exist yes
right we saw that it did can it be
computed efficiently
yes using SOS convexity and then the
last question is is this decomposition
unique and quite trivially the answer to
this is No
so why is this if I give you an initial
decomposition right f is equal to G
minus H then I can add anything convex
on the left hand side subtract on the
right hand side and I get a completely
new decomposition so this bag is the
question as to what would be the best
decomposition right I have an infinite
number to pick from and what would I
pick as a best decomposition so that
really depends on what you want to do
with this decomposition right so in our
particular case we're interested in
solving problems of this type these
difference of convex programs
so what we're interested in is a
decomposition that favours heuristics
for minimizing these kind of problems
and the particular heuristic we're
concerned with is a convex concave
procedure occp so I'm gonna explain how
it works and then I'm gonna tell you
what would be a good decomposition for
this kind of heuristic the idea is very
easy so it's an idea t'v algorithm so
you start with an initial point x0 and
you have your decompositions right of
these functions fi into G I minus H I so
what do you do you provide these convex
if I'd versions of your functions fi of
X so you can verify how by keeping the
convex part GI of X and by linearizing
the concave part around the current
iterate okay so this gives you so this
part will be a fine this part will be
convex and so the resulting function
will be convex - so what does this look
like so typically if you have a non
convex function here it's convex if I'd
version around the point x0 equals 2 is
this orange curve here ok and then you
solve the convex sub-problem so you
replace every single fi in this
formulation here by its convex if I'd
version this is a convex optimization
problem you solve it and you get your
next iterate and you repeat so on a toy
example what does this look like so here
minimizing this function here and I know
that F can be written as G minus H and
I'm going to start at the point x0 plus
2 I'm going to convective find my
function around X 0 equals 2 I'm gonna
get this orange curve here I'm going to
minimize this orange curve I'm gonna get
x1 I'm going to convex if I again around
this blue curve get x2 and so on and so
forth and eventually I'm going to
converge this local minimum
okay so what would it mean to pick a
good decomposition for this algorithm
right so the main idea in this algorithm
is this linearizing part so you have
your decomposition right you linearize
you're concave part - H of X to obtain
this convex if I'd version of your
function so what would be a good idea to
do the good idea here would be to
minimize the curvature of edge so to
pick H as close as possible to a line
already so that way when you linearize
you're not losing much information and
how do we do this we minimize the
curvature of H and so the way so
curvatures are local property so we want
you to come up with a global kind of
formulation of this and this is how we
came up with the idea of an undated
decomposition so what is an underman
ated decomposition so G and H are an
undated decomposition of F right
if you can't obtain any other
decomposition of F by subtracting
something convex from H so essentially
you're ready you can't get anything you
can't take anything convex out of H and
get another valid decomposition and so
how does this translate how does this
impact the CCP algorithm well if you
remember right so this is our function
so this is the function we're interested
in so let's look at this on a tour
example so this is a function we're
interested in and we have two different
decomposition savage this Orange
decomposition and is gray decomposition
here so f is equal to G minus H and G
prime minus H prime now this orange
decomposition here is dominated by this
gray decomposition here why is that
because I can subtract x squared right
from H here and obtain this
decomposition here which is still a
valid decomposition and on one iteration
of the CCP algorithm what does this look
like so this is my convex if I'd version
of f using the orange decomposition and
this one using the gray decomposition
and remember that in our algorithm we
would take the minimum afterwards right
and this gray curve here is lower than
this orange curve so it gives us a
better minimum so essentially taking a
none dominated decomposition it gives us
the next best thing to do in the CCP
algorithm it gives us the best possible
thing we can do in one step and how do
we obtain the Sun dominated
decomposition well it's actually the
solution to the following optimization
problem and we've shown that such a
solution always exists so a dominant
dominated decomposition always exists to
so here we have so this is the
optimization problem in question so here
we have F is equal to G minus H so
that's the constraint so we're looking
for G H right so we have F is equal to G
minus H G is convex H is convex
so this is just asking this is just
giving me a feasible decomposition right
and what is giving me the undeveloped H
which is a matrix of polynomials we take
its trace that gives us a polynomial we
integrate it over the sphere and that
gives us something that's linear in the
coefficients of H and that's the kind of
problem that we're going to be solving
so actually solving a problem of this
type is hard
due to the convexity condition so what
we're going to do is we're going to
replace this convexity conditioned by
s.o.s convexity condition and this is
going to be in a semi definite program
to solve so how does it perform in
practice so to compare if our
decomposition actually works and gives
us something valuable what we did is we
were interested in minimizing a function
f 0 so f 0 has was generated randomly it
has 8 variables of its of degree 4 and
we're minimizing it over a ball and what
we're going to do is we're good to
decompose this function into two using
two different tools so one of them is
just going to be a pure feasibility
problem the other one is going to be
this undated decomposition so we're
going to decompose it in two different
ways and then we're going to run this
algorithm on the two different
decompositions we're going to stop it
our four minutes and see the objective
value that we're going to get at the end
and of course the lower the better right
we're minimizing so if the objective
value is lower then it would have
performed better and these are the
results we get
so we're feasibility here we're going to
get a very high objective value and
where the son dominated decomposition
we're actually getting a much lower
objective value so it shows that the
performance of this algorithm is
strongly impacted by it by such a
decomposition and in fact it might even
be valuable for you if you already have
such a decomposition to recompute one to
actually get better results so just to
conclude so I've shown you know
hopefully I've convinced you that
optimizing over known non negative
polynomials has many applications here
we saw two such applications and machine
learning so monitoring regression and
difference of convex programming so
future directions that we have and I
already talked a little bit about the
first
in his in his talk is about you know
improving scalability of semi-definite
programs so many different programs are
not touristy you know not scalable
so we've been working on on algorithms
to solve large-scale semi-definite
programs and the second one that we're
interested in and that we're looking at
currently is using these difference of
convex programs ideas that I talked
about for sparse regression so in this
particular case this is linear
regression right so I'm trying to find a
least squares fit and then I have this
regularizing condition I want to run to
my my solution to be sparse so I'm
adding the zero norm right and
traditionally what we do is we replace
this zero none by a one norm which is
convex and then we we solve this problem
but it might be better to have for
example concave approximation so a
polynomial that approximates my non zero
instead of having a non one that
approximately nonzero and but then this
would become a non convex polynomial and
what we would do is we would use this
algorithm to obtain a decomposition of
this polynomial and then use a CCP
algorithm to obtain solutions to this
program so those are future directions
thanks very much
[Applause]
so I uniqueness partisan so the
uniqueness of the decomposition we
identified a nice way of writing way
so let me let me go back are you talking
about the short answer is no so it's
very it's quite easy to see right so
suppose you have this initial
decomposition here F is equal to G minus
H right you can add if you have a
colleague's and to pick your favorite
convex polynomial right add it onto G
and it onto H they cancel each other out
so it's still equal to F but it's
another decomposition
so the question is whether the
unterminated decomposition is unique I
guess yes so actually so in the case
where so okay so in the quadratic case
for example it's non unique so we can
assume that under Malaysia
decompositions are not unique in general
so we'll give you one such decomposition
the quadratic asus underman ated
decompositions are not unique there's a
paper by bombs where he shows that them
so you don't get this so that's one of
them but their office
objective for the undulating this thing
so actually does there's well-known
techniques for computing this integral
so there's again another paper actually
that gives you explicit the explicit the
integral explicitly as a function of the
coefficients it's just it's known yet
like what if you're gonna go first I
mean I guess you're having here for one
step yes so this is so this is
essentially a greedy method right so
every step it's the best thing to do so
they'll know we don't have any
theoretical guarantees anywhere has to
like the the experimentally is the only
thing we have but it seems to perform
what experiment
other questions and your regression
problem so this is just me squares any
squares is a quadratic yeah
least squares justification is that it's
the maximum likelihood for for the
normal distribution when you impose when
you impose any kind of condition like
one of the density then you are the
normal would I don't think the normal
distribution would be appropriate
because the support is the entire space
and here now you're saying solve this
space is allowed so that yeah so we
would so if I understand your question
correctly I we would restrict ourselves
at least for the beginning on to the
interval 0 1 is that your question it's
just that the least squares is
justifiable you're assuming the normal
distribution on the on the graph and the
parameter space so this was just an
example to be honest with you you can
replace by any polynomial loss that you
that you prefer and
Georgina
[Applause]